so you've built your machine learning
models and now it's time to take them to
production
what do you need to do stay tuned to
find out
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning
i am priyanka vergaria and today we are
going to talk about
managing production machine learning
pipelines
as you've seen through years of ai
adventures machine learning is a lot of
fun
and is much more than just a novelty
machine learning models power so many
technologies in our lives
and there are plenty of new and better
models just waiting to be applied to the
real world
so how do you transition from
experimenting with a model
to actually moving it to production well
just as you need a quality ci cd
pipeline to maintain a robust code base
at scale
you need a machine learning pipeline to
help you monitor
transform evaluate and serve your models
in production
what are the different steps involved in
a machine learning workflow
well first you ingest the input data set
and split it for training
evaluation and testing then validate it
identify and remove anomalies from that
data or handle redundant features
and empty values you might have to
address the detected issues
may be finding more training data for
certain categories
then you do feature engineering to
transform the data and enrich the
features to improve your training
at which point the model is ready to
train and tune
once trained evaluate the model to make
sure it generalizes
well enough to use in production when
the model gets the green light
you push it to production this
production environment needs to be
powerful enough to support the rate of
inference required by your application
now when does this ml workflow becomes
a pipeline well it's when we
automate it and the automation is
necessary especially if we want to
deploy these models in production
so the question now becomes how do we
automate the machine learning workflow
tasks
to create an end-to-end pipeline for
deploying
our models into production here is a
very high level architecture of how it
works
tensorflow is running on tfx which in
turn is running inside kubeflow
pipelines
and that's running on gke leveraging the
google cloud services
you can create pipelines with similar
functionality
using both kubeflow pipelines and
tensorflow extended sdks
we have an entire series on kubeflow
which i have linked below
in this video let's focus on tensorflow
extended or tfx which is an open source
end-to-end platform specifically
designed for
scalable high-performance machine
learning tasks
here's how it works a tfx pipeline is
a sequence of components implementing
the ml workflow tasks
and they are built using open source tfx
libraries
which can also be used individually this
is sort of a canonical tfx pipeline
you can think of it as hello world
pipeline
these orange components come out of the
box with tensorflow extended
but you can create your own components
as well
once the model is ready you deploy it
into a serving cluster in tensorflow
serving tensorflow.js
tensorflow lite tensorflow hub or even
ai platform predictions
now what is a tfx component
it is essentially a task that we perform
in our machine learning pipeline
it has a config and it takes input from
the metadata
except for the very first component
which is ingesting the data set from the
original data source
it takes those inputs using an input
channel
does its task and generates the output
artifact
and then uses the output channel to put
those back
into the metadata and that's how
components communicate with each other
the upstream components will produce an
artifact that the downstream component
depends on
and the data flows through the pipeline
by flowing through these dependencies
in the metadata now what is metadata
well it allows us to trace the lineage
of the artifacts that are produced
for example what data is the model
trained with
metadata can also be used to compare
previous training runs
it also allows tracking and reuse of
previously computed outputs
which saves quite a bit of time
especially for larger data sets and
models
if the input to the component has not
changed
we don't want to rerun the component we
should just be able to pull the last
result from the cache
and reuse it now let's go back to our
standard components and understand
them a little bit more first off example
gen helps us ingest our data from csv
files bigquery presto etc it splits the
data
and saves it off as tf examples and tf
record files statistics jen
will make a full pass over that data and
calculate statistics about it
that's important to understand our data
if it is new
and if it has changed over time schema
gen then determines the schema across
our data such as what are the types of
our features
and for the categorical variables what
are the valid categories
example validator takes both of those
results
and looks for problems things like the
examples that have the wrong
type in the particular feature or a
categorical value that should not be
there
transform is where the feature
engineering is done
it will convert the feature engineering
that we want to do
with a graph that becomes part of our
model
trainer takes that graph and the model
that we have defined using tensorflow
and trains that model evaluator takes
that trained model and does a deep
analysis of the performance of that
model
it looks at not just the entire data set
but also the individual slices
of a data to try to understand how
performance varies across different
parts of our data
it can be used for fairness analysis
like seeing if your model is performing
differently
for different types of model users
infra validator makes sure that we can
actually deploy
our model to our serving infrastructure
if both evaluator and
infra validator agree that yes we can
deploy our model
our evaluator has checked to make sure
that the model is actually better than
what we have in production
then the pusher will push it to one of
our deployment targets
so that was a quick overview of
tensorflow extended which helps us
engineer
our machine learning pipelines so we can
deploy our models
in production in the next episode we
will see tfx
and kubrow pipelines in action in cloud
ai platform pipelines
until then i would love to hear the
topics that will help you get better at
machine learning and ai
drop them in the comments below and
don't forget to like and subscribe